This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The night of December 8, 2013, a huge crowd appeared on a tree-lined boulevard in downtown Kiev, the capital of Ukraine. The crowd was there to watch, as a statue in the boulevard was pulled down by a crane. That's producer Julia Barton. It's a pretty large statue, a little more than 11 feet tall, and as it topples to the ground, the crowd goes wild. The toppled statue was a Vladimir Linnon, the Communist leader who started the revolution that created the Soviet Union, of which Ukraine was once a part.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2013年12月8日晚，乌克兰首都基辅市中心的一条林荫大道上聚集了大量人群。人群聚集在那里，是为了观看一台起重机将大道上的一座雕像拉倒。那是制片人朱莉娅·巴顿。那是一座相当大的雕像，高约11英尺多，当它轰然倒地时，人群沸腾了。被推倒的雕像是弗拉基米尔·列宁，他是发动革命并创建苏联的共产主义领袖，而乌克兰曾是苏联的一部分。
The sculpture had shown Linnon striding into a breezy future, one that just barely rippled his marble suit coat. But on the night of December 8, 2013, this Lenin was no longer striding into a breezy future, he was lying on the cold concrete, as monument need to be ruined. And that he's a killer. And that it's not the place for Soviet shit here anymore. And Ukrainians are owners of this land. Ukrainian photojournalist Alexander Tchentsky rushed to the scene that night.
这座雕塑展现了列宁大步迈向微风拂面的未来，那微风甚至几乎没有吹动他大理石材质的西装外套。但在2013年12月8日那个晚上，这位列宁不再是迈向微风拂面的未来，他躺在冰冷的混凝土上，因为纪念碑需要被摧毁。而且他是个杀人犯。这里不再是苏联垃圾的容身之地了。乌克兰人才是这片土地的主人。乌克兰摄影记者亚历山大·切恩茨基当晚赶到了现场。
He and his colleagues kept their camera steady as the drama unfolded around them. Their footage ended up in a documentary they later made called All Things Oblays. It shows people taking sledgehammers to Lenin's torso. The camera lingers on one man in a shiny tracksuit who spits on his hand, crosses himself three times, and starts whacking away with all his might. But at some point, a thin old guy in a black coat emerges from the crowd and just wraps himself around Lenin's chest. Yeah, he was trying to protect Len with his own body.
当戏剧性的一幕在他们周围展开时，他和同事们稳稳地拿着摄像机。他们的镜头最终被收录进后来制作的纪录片《万物皆逝》中。片中显示人们用大锤砸向列宁的躯干。镜头停留在一个穿着亮面运动服的男人身上，他往手上吐了口唾沫，在胸前画了三次十字，然后用尽全力猛砸。但在某个时刻，一个穿着黑色外套、瘦弱的老人从人群中走出来，紧紧抱住了列宁的胸部。是的，他试图用自己的身体保护列宁。
And did he say anything other so time? Yeah, he was saying that it's not right, it's not correct. Please don't do that. It's a barbarism. Barbarism. Barbarism, yeah. Another man pats the old communists on the back, a little threateningly. back, a little threateningly. He's saying to this old communist sympathizer,
除了那个时刻，他还说了什么吗？是的，他说这样做是不对的，是不正确的。请不要这样做。这是野蛮行径。野蛮行径。野蛮行径，是的。另一个人带着一点威胁的意味拍了拍这位老共产党员的背。他在对这位老共产主义同情者说：
you're the last one in the whole city, in the whole country understand, when you die, things in this country will get better. Eventually, some volunteers and reflective vests lead the old man away by the arms. His hat is gone. He looks ready to fate." For the protesters, this old man and this statue of Lenin represent old Ukraine, one that is associated with the Soviet Union and with Russia. The protesters saw themselves as
你是整个城市、整个国家最后一个这样想的人，你要明白，当你死后，这个国家的情况会好转。最终，一些穿着反光背心的志愿者架着老人的双臂将他带走。他的帽子不见了。他看起来准备好迎接命运了。对于抗议者来说，这位老人和这座列宁雕像代表了旧乌克兰，一个与苏联和俄罗斯联系在一起的乌克兰。抗议者们将自己视为
new Ukraine, independent and allied with the European Union. The same protests that brought down that Lenin statue eventually brought about a new government in Ukraine, and that new government in Ukraine. And that new government has been trying to get rid of all kinds of physical reminders of communism and of Russia. Lenin statues, names of streets and towns. But it hasn't always been easy to get rid of these things, logistically or politically, because it erases a part of history that is still important to some Ukrainians. People in a different parts of Ukraine can see that history difference. because it erases a part of history that is still important to some Ukrainians.
新乌克兰，独立并与欧盟结盟。正是推倒那座列宁雕像的同一场抗议活动，最终在乌克兰催生了一个新政府，而那个新政府一直在试图清除各种关于共产主义和俄罗斯的物质遗迹。列宁雕像、街道和城镇的名称。但要从后勤或政治上清除这些东西并不总是那么容易，因为它抹去了一部分对一些乌克兰人来说仍然重要的历史。乌克兰不同地区的人们对那段历史的看法各不相同。
People in a different parts of Ukraine can see that history different. That's Katarina Draunova. She's the legal editor at VoxUcrain.org, a website for Ukrainian news and policy analysis. For someone who is a history of oppression for someone, it is the history of, you know, having your town been developed under the Soviet rule in the process of industrialization. To understand all this, we should zoom out a bit. Ukraine is a country about the size of Texas
乌克兰不同地区的人们对那段历史的看法各不相同。那是卡塔琳娜·德劳诺娃。她是VoxUcrain.org的法律编辑，这是一个提供乌克兰新闻和政策分析的网站。对于一个有压迫历史的人来说，这就是在苏联统治下的工业化进程中，你的城镇被开发的历史。要理解这一切，我们需要稍微拉远视角。乌克兰是一个面积大约相当于德克萨斯州的国家，
that is bordered by Russia to the east and the rest of Europe to the west. So it's nestled right between two superpowers, the European Union and Russia. A lot of people in the U.S. still refer to Ukraine as the Ukraine, like the Midwest or the South. A region. It drives Ukrainians crazy. But there is a reason for the mistake. For centuries, Ukraine was a region controlled by more powerful entities around it, and the word Ukraine literally means borderland.
东临俄罗斯，西接欧洲其他地区。所以它正好坐落在两个超级大国——欧盟和俄罗斯之间。许多美国人仍然称乌克兰为“The Ukraine”，就像称呼中西部或南部一样，指代一个地区。这让乌克兰人非常抓狂。但这个错误是有原因的。几个世纪以来，乌克兰一直是一个被周围更强大的实体所控制的地区，而“乌克兰”这个词字面意思就是“边境之地”。
In the 1920s, much of the territory of Ukraine became part of the Soviet Union, despite the efforts of a lot of people who wanted it to be an independent country. In the 1930s, millions of Ukrainians died in a famine that stole and engineered by forcibly taking food from peasants and trapping them into starvation. It was the policy of collectivization.
20世纪20年代，尽管许多人努力争取让乌克兰成为一个独立国家，但其大部分领土还是成为了苏联的一部分。20世纪30年代，数百万乌克兰人在一场饥荒中丧生，这场饥荒是通过强行从农民手中夺走粮食并让他们陷入饥饿而蓄意策划的。这就是集体化政策。
They would take away the possessions of the people. They would collect the grain from farms and people were starving. Many scholars believe Stalin did this specifically to cripple the movement for Ukrainian independence. A decade later during World War II, hundreds of thousands of Ukrainians, especially people in the East,
他们会夺走人们的财产。他们会从农场收集粮食，而人们却在挨饿。许多学者认为，斯大林这样做是为了专门削弱乌克兰的独立运动。十年后的二战期间，成千上万的乌克兰人，特别是东部地区的人，
near what is now Russia, fought and died with the Soviet Red Army. But a smaller, especially people in the east, near what is now Russia, fought and died with the Soviet Red Army. But a smaller number of people in the west, who wanted an independent Ukraine, allied themselves with the Nazis. And the Soviet Union and Germany both wanted control over Ukrainian territory. The territory of Ukraine was the territory of clashes during the Second World War. When it was all over, even more of Ukraine was part of the USSR. Soviet authorities, one of the people of Ukraine,
靠近现在俄罗斯的地方，与苏联红军并肩作战并牺牲。但西部地区的一小部分人，因为想要一个独立的乌克兰，与纳粹结盟了。苏联和德国都想控制乌克兰领土。乌克兰领土是第二次世界大战期间冲突的焦点。当一切结束时，更多的乌克兰领土成为了苏联的一部分。苏联当局，乌克兰人民的意愿，
denied around the narrative that they had defeated the Nazis and that communism would help the country rebuild. The war was destroyed. It was the story about winning the war and coming back victoriously and trying to rebuild the country from scratch. They had to find this inner resource to relaunch the country again, and it was very hard because they came back to empty houses if houses at all, because the territory of Ukraine was heavily bombed.
否认了他们击败纳粹、共产主义将帮助国家重建的叙事。战争被摧毁了。这是一个关于赢得战争、胜利归来并试图从零开始重建国家的故事。他们必须找到这种内在资源来重新启动国家，这非常困难，因为他们回到的是空房子，如果还有房子的话，因为乌克兰的领土遭到了猛烈轰炸。
As part of a campaign to unite Ukraine under the banner of communism, the Soviets put statues of the USSR's founding father Vladimir Lenin everywhere. Ukraine eventually had around 5,500 statues of Lenin. In the whole territory of Russia, which is 28 times the size of Ukraine, there were about 7,000 Lenins. Apart from covering Ukraine in Lenin's, the Soviet Union did help develop and rebuild Ukraine in the years after World War II. Small villages became big industrial cities. But the Soviet regime also imprisoned by some estimates around 2 million Ukrainians in
作为在共产主义旗帜下统一乌克兰运动的一部分，苏联人在各地竖立了苏联开国元勋弗拉基米尔·列宁的雕像。乌克兰最终拥有了大约5500座列宁雕像。而在面积是乌克兰28倍的俄罗斯全境，大约有7000座列宁雕像。除了用列宁雕像覆盖乌克兰外，苏联确实在二战后的几年里帮助开发和重建了乌克兰。小村庄变成了大型工业城市。但苏联政权也据估计监禁了大约200万乌克兰人于
Gulags. Because the Soviet Union was not a free society with a free press, many people had no idea that kind of repression was happening. This whole oppression and building up labor camps and Gulag in the USSR and this information was not disclosed so people didn't have access to that information. The USSR said, everything is fine as they put up more and more Lenin statues all over Ukraine. Ukraine eventually became the most Leninized territory in the USSR. The Chief State TV channel was halfway through its evening news
古拉格。因为苏联不是一个拥有自由媒体的自由社会，许多人根本不知道那种压迫正在发生。这种压迫、建立劳改营和古拉格的信息在苏联并没有被披露，所以人们无法获得这些信息。苏联说，一切都很好，同时在乌克兰各地竖立了越来越多的列宁雕像。乌克兰最终成为了苏联境内“列宁化”程度最高的地区。国家电视台的主频道在晚间新闻播报到一半时，
when it got the first details of the agreement signed in Minsk. Quoting from it, the anchor woman announced, the Soviet Union no longer exists. In 1991, the Soviet Union collapsed. Ukraine became its own separate country and so did Russia. But Russia hung on to its Soviet past. Russia, after the collapse of the USSR, officially announced that it is the successor of the USSR. It's kind of the same. They have the music in the national anthem, it's the same. It's just the words that the USSR. It's kind of the same, the music in the national anthem is the same, it's just the words that have changed. [♪ Music playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the background, the music is playing in the music is playing of the country, especially current president Vladimir Putin, never stopped
收到了在明斯克签署的协议的初步细节。主播引用协议内容宣布，苏联不复存在了。1991年，苏联解体。乌克兰成为了一个独立的国家，俄罗斯也是。但俄罗斯紧紧抓住了它的苏联过去。苏联解体后，俄罗斯正式宣布自己是苏联的继承者。这有点像是一回事。他们的国歌音乐是一样的，只是歌词变了。
being proud of the Soviet legacy. Ukraine meanwhile has struggled with its identity, since gaining its independence in 1991. For a very long time, Ukraine was very indecisive, I would say, in international politics. With the country-oriented East, towards Russia, or West, towards Europe. It was hard for Ukraine to completely cut ties with Russia, for one they relied on it for coal and gas. But also, many Ukrainians have strong cultural connections to Russia. Ukrainians have a lot of relatives living in Russia. It's culture, it's family,
一直为苏联遗产感到自豪。与此同时，自1991年获得独立以来，乌克兰一直在为自己的身份而挣扎。很长一段时间里，我想说，乌克兰在国际政治中非常优柔寡断。国家是向东面向俄罗斯，还是向西面向欧洲。乌克兰很难完全切断与俄罗斯的联系，一方面他们依赖俄罗斯的煤炭和天然气。但同时，许多乌克兰人与俄罗斯有着深厚的文化联系。乌克兰人有很多亲戚住在俄罗斯。这是文化，是家庭，
and it's business relationship, too, because both nations speak the same language. It's very easy to carry out business activities. For years, the countries seem to vacillate. Some presidents of Ukraine lean west towards Europe, others oriented east toward Russia. And all of those led in statues and other communist symbols in the built environment? In Western Ukraine, where people felt less loyalty to the Soviet era, they got rid of most of them right after independence. But in the rest of Ukraine, they mostly stayed put. The will to remove them just wasn't there.
也是商业关系，因为两国说同一种语言。开展商业活动非常容易。多年来，这些国家似乎摇摆不定。乌克兰的一些总统倾向于向西面向欧洲，另一些则向东面向俄罗斯。那么那些列宁雕像和建筑环境中的其他共产主义符号呢？在西乌克兰，人们对苏联时代的忠诚度较低，他们在独立后立即清除了大部分雕像。但在乌克兰的其他地区，它们大多保留了下来。移除它们的意愿并不强烈。
And then in 2013, the pro-Russian president Viktor Yanukovych tried to back out of a deal to bring Ukraine closer to joining the European Union. Huge protests broke out. The tide had turned. Ukrainians were in the streets saying they didn't want to be beholden to Russia anymore. These are the same protests that led to the Lenin statue being torn down in Kiev, the one that you heard at the beginning of the story.
然后到了2013年，亲俄总统维克多·亚努科维奇试图退出一项让乌克兰更接近加入欧盟的协议。大规模抗议爆发了。风向变了。乌克兰人走上街头，表示他们不想再受制于俄罗斯。这些就是导致基辅列宁雕像被推倒的同一场抗议活动，也就是你在故事开头听到的那一幕。
But that's not the only statue that came down. People started spontaneously tearing down Lenin's all over Ukraine. So much so that they had a name for it. Leninopod, or the falling of the Lenin's. In February of 2014, following days of bloody protests in which more than 100 protesters were killed, Victor Yanukovych was forced out of the presidency and fled Russia. The protesters in Ukraine established a new government. It had been a violent and shocking few days for Ukraine, but ultimately the protest of
但那并不是唯一被推倒的雕像。人们开始自发地在乌克兰各地推倒列宁雕像。以至于他们为此起了一个名字。列宁倒塌（Leninopod），或者说列宁的陨落。2014年2月，在经历了数天的血腥抗议、造成100多名抗议者死亡后，维克多·亚努科维奇被迫下台并逃往俄罗斯。乌克兰的抗议者建立了一个新政府。这对乌克兰来说是暴力且令人震惊的几天，但最终抗议者
the victorious in their aims to topple Yanukovych and install a new government. Russian President Vladimir Putin didn't like that Ukraine was turning away from Russia and toward the European Union, and in March of 2014 he expressed that by taking control of a part of Ukraine called Crimea. This morning more unidentified pro-Russia armed militias controlling the streets of Crimea's capital. Meanwhile, hundreds of miles to the east. Russian-backed separatists started fighting the Ukrainian
在推翻亚努科维奇并建立新政府的目标上取得了胜利。俄罗斯总统弗拉基米尔·普京不喜欢乌克兰背离俄罗斯转向欧盟，于是在2014年3月，他通过控制乌克兰的一部分领土——克里米亚，表达了这一点。今天早上，更多身份不明的亲俄武装民兵控制了克里米亚首府的街道。与此同时，在数百英里外的东部，俄罗斯支持的分离主义分子开始与乌克兰
military. Those battles continue today. At least 10,000 people have died. By the end of 2014, Ukraine's new government, now definitively oriented towards the west, had inherited a country in crisis. You might think Lenin removal would be at the bottom of their list. But battles with the separatists made the government want to rid its landscape once and for all of its Soviet past, which was linked with the enemy, Russia. When you have lost a certain territory and you're likely to lose another territory on the east. And you have the community that is extremely polarized the West and East and dismantling Lenin monuments and dismantling the Soviet past in general is a big, very, very powerful
军队作战。这些战斗一直持续到今天。至少有1万人死亡。到2014年底，乌克兰的新政府，现在明确地转向西方，接手了一个处于危机中的国家。你可能认为移除列宁雕像会是他们清单上最不重要的事情。但与分离主义分子的战斗使政府想要彻底清除其景观中与敌人俄罗斯联系在一起的苏联过去。当你失去了一定领土，并且很可能在东部失去更多领土时，而且你面对的是一个极度两极分化的社会（西部和东部），那么拆除列宁纪念碑和拆除苏联过去在总体上是一个巨大且非常有力的
symbol. One year after coming to power, the new government led by Petro Poroshenko decided to make the falling of the Lenins into state policy. His allies in Ukraine's parliament passed a package of bills called decommunization laws. Various post-Soviet countries had already passed similar laws. In Ukraine, these laws did a number of things to outlaw communism, one of which was to ban communist symbols. Local authorities had a year to get rid of their Lenin statues.
象征。上台一年后，由彼得·波罗申科领导的新政府决定将“列宁倒塌”作为国家政策。他在乌克兰议会的盟友通过了一揽子被称为“去共产主义化法”的法案。各个后苏联国家此前已经通过了类似的法律。在乌克兰，这些法律采取了多种措施来取缔共产主义，其中之一就是禁止共产主义符号。地方当局有一年的时间来处理掉他们的列宁雕像。
If their town or streets had communist names, those had to be changed too. Ukrainians in Harcoph have celebrated the toppling of a monument to former Soviet leader Vladimir Lenin. A 20-meter statue of Soviet dictator Vladimir Lenin has been taken down in the Ukrainian city of Zappolin. Another day, another Lenin monument falls in Ukraine's war-torn east.
如果他们的城镇或街道有共产主义名称，这些也必须更改。哈尔科夫的乌克兰人庆祝了前苏联领导人弗拉基米尔·列宁纪念碑的倒塌。一座20米高的苏联独裁者弗拉基米尔·列宁的雕像在乌克兰城市扎波罗热被拆除。又是一天，又一座列宁纪念碑在乌克兰饱受战争蹂躏的东部倒下。
Some places in Ukraine got really creative about complying with the decommunization laws. A factory in Odessa hired a sculptor to refashion the figure of Lenin as Darth Vader. Overseen the removal of all these symbols is a government organization, the Ukrainian Institute of National Remembrance. I'm Alina Schbach. I'm the deputy head of the Ukrainian Institute of National Remembrance. I'm Alina Spock. I'm the deputy head of Ukrainian Institute of National Remembrance. Spock told me it's not easy to go from totalitarianism to democracy. That's a very complicated process, definitely. Coming from a totalitarian society up to democratic society.
乌克兰的一些地方在遵守去共产主义化法律方面非常有创意。敖德萨的一家工厂聘请了一位雕塑家，将列宁的形象改造成了达斯·维达。负责监督所有这些符号移除工作的是一个政府组织——乌克兰国家记忆研究所。我是阿丽娜·什巴赫。我是乌克兰国家记忆研究所的副所长。什巴赫告诉我，从极权主义走向民主并不容易。这绝对是一个非常复杂的过程。从极权社会走向民主社会。
It's also not easy to erase communism from the built environment. The Soviets made things to last. There are long bridges lined with rot iron hammers and sickles. There are whole forests planted in such a way that if you fly over, you see the cerilic initials for the USSR. And there are neighborhoods that do this too. In Ternopil, for example, when we have a set of building which were built up in such a way so we are stuck in struct letters of USSR letters with buildings.
从建筑环境中抹去共产主义也不容易。苏联人制造的东西经久耐用。有长长的桥梁，上面排列着锻铁锤子和镰刀。有整片的森林，种植方式使得如果你从空中飞过，就能看到西里尔字母的“苏联”缩写。有些社区也是这样做的。例如在捷尔诺波尔，我们有一组建筑，它们的建造方式使得我们被困在用建筑组成的“苏联”字母中。
That's one communist symbol that may have to stay for now. Schbach says the process of decommunizing isn't just about removal, it's also meant to help Ukrainians learn their own history. Which is why in many cases, the Institute of National Remembrance has suggested that towns revert to the names they had before the Soviets change them. This is actually what happened to Katarina Draunovitz hometown. The Institute of National Remembers made a proposition to restore the historical name of the town.
那是目前可能必须保留的一个共产主义符号。什巴赫说，去共产主义化的过程不仅仅是移除，它还旨在帮助乌克兰人了解他们自己的历史。这就是为什么在许多情况下，国家记忆研究所建议城镇恢复苏联更改之前的名称。这实际上就是卡塔琳娜·德劳诺维茨家乡发生的事情。国家记忆研究所提出了恢复该镇历史名称的建议。
In 2016, the name of her town was restored to come in skia. It is rooted back to 1750 when there were Kosoks settlements. The Soviet name of Katarina's town that it had up until 2016 was Nipro-Jerjinsk. Nipro-Jerjinsk and it's absolutely unpronounceable even for natives. In John of the town, the majority of people just wanted to keep the old, unpronounceable Soviet name, because she says it was just a tiny village before the Soviets set up a metallurgical plant there. The city owes its very existence to the Soviet history.
2016年，她家乡的名字被恢复为卡缅斯克。它的根源可以追溯到1750年，当时那里有哥萨克定居点。卡塔琳娜家乡在2016年之前的苏联名称是第聂伯罗捷尔任斯克。第聂伯罗捷尔任斯克，即使对当地人来说也绝对无法发音。在城镇里，大多数人只是想保留那个古老、无法发音的苏联名字，因为她说在苏联人建立冶金厂之前，那只是一个小村庄。这座城市的存在本身就归功于苏联历史。
It has become a town, it has become so big because of the Soviet rule, so it does make sense that there was a big part of the population that opposed to change. But in the end, it didn't matter if the people wanted to keep the name. Their town was named for a prominent Soviet figure, Felix Durginski, who founded the Soviet secret police, and the new law mandated the town's name be changed.
它之所以成为一个城镇，之所以变得如此之大，是因为苏联的统治，所以确实有一大部分人口反对改变是有道理的。但最终，人们是否想保留这个名字并不重要。他们的城镇是以一位著名的苏联人物费利克斯·捷尔任斯基命名的，他创立了苏联秘密警察，而新法律规定必须更改城镇名称。
What local communities do not have is the choice to keep the Soviet names. That's Tariq Cyril Amar, a historian of Ukraine and Eastern Europe at Columbia University in New York. This type of, as I would say, fairly ham-fisted attempt at dealing with the Soviet legacy is actually reproducing some of the Soviet legacy, some of the habits of doing things to Soviet way. And this is a major criticism of the decommunization loss that Ukraine is being kind of authoritarian
地方社区没有选择保留苏联名称的权利。那是塔里克·西里尔·阿马尔，纽约哥伦比亚大学的乌克兰和东欧历史学家。这种我所说的相当笨拙的处理苏联遗产的尝试，实际上是在复制一些苏联遗产，一些用苏联方式做事的习惯。这是对去共产主义化法律的一个主要批评，即乌克兰在某种程度上表现得专制，
about separating from their authoritarian past. Not just because people don't get to say in whether they change the name of their town, but because the laws also make it illegal to join the Communist Party or display any kind of Soviet symbols or to deny the quote criminal nature of the Soviet regime. It is forbidden to deny the criminal nature and the criminal nature is not defined so we're not even sure about what we're not allowed to deny a question. Scholars we spoke to for this story oppose these parts of the decommunization laws, the ones that seem to limit freedom of speech and freedom of expression. Drawniva believes the law is too ambiguous. It's unclear if, for example, wearing a t-shirt with Karl Marx on it could make you criminally liable.
关于与他们的专制过去分离。不仅是因为人们无法决定是否更改城镇名称，还因为这些法律还规定加入共产党、展示任何形式的苏联符号或否认苏联政权的“犯罪性质”是非法的。禁止否认其犯罪性质，而“犯罪性质”并没有被定义，所以我们甚至不确定我们被禁止否认的是什么。我们为这个故事采访的学者反对去共产主义化法律的这些部分，那些似乎限制言论自由和表达自由的部分。德劳诺娃认为法律太模糊了。例如，不清楚穿一件印有卡尔·马克思的T恤是否会让你承担刑事责任。
Since the formal process of removing communist symbols began in 2014, more than 50,000 objects have been renamed. This includes cities, towns, villages, streets, squares, and parks. And more than 2,000 monuments and memorials have been taken down or modified. In general, these changes have been hardest on Ukraine's older population. The people who lived under Soviet rule who didn't understand how bad it was for some people. Because there wasn't a free press or freedom in academia, the extent of the repression was hidden from the general public.
自2014年正式开始移除共产主义符号以来，已有超过5万个对象被重新命名。这包括城市、城镇、村庄、街道、广场和公园。超过2000座纪念碑和纪念物被拆除或修改。总的来说，这些变化对乌克兰的老年人口打击最大。那些生活在苏联统治下、不了解这对某些人来说有多糟糕的人。因为没有自由媒体或学术自由，压迫的程度对公众是隐瞒的。
Some Ukrainians are now just funny now that millions of people died because of Stalin, and that millions more were put into Gulags. These notions of oppressions, the facts and statistics, come to them as a big revelation right now, and there is a denial. There's been a lot of change in Ukraine in the past couple of decades, and it's still volatile. Over a million people have been displaced, and some eastern parts of the country are locked in semi-permanent conflict with Russia. You live in this permanent condition of not knowing what's going to happen next and what
一些乌克兰人现在才刚刚发现，数百万人因为斯大林而死亡，还有数百万人被关进古拉格。这些关于压迫的概念、事实和统计数据，对他们来说现在是一个巨大的启示，而且存在否认。过去几十年来，乌克兰发生了很大变化，而且仍然不稳定。超过一百万人流离失所，该国东部的一些地区陷入了与俄罗斯的半永久性冲突中。你生活在这种不知道接下来会发生什么、不知道
to expect, that's why it is easier for someone who has been living under the Soviet troops feeling nostalgic about it. Donovan says that for now, many Ukrainians have shifted away from wanting to be allied with Russia and toward wanting to be allied with the EU. But Russia still exerts a lot of political influence, and there are pro-Russia forces within the country that could cause trouble for a long time. Despite feeling like some parts of the decommunization laws are too ambiguous, Dronova thinks that removing communist symbols in public spaces is an important
期待什么的永久状态中，这就是为什么对于那些生活在苏联军队统治下的人来说，怀念它更容易。德劳诺娃说，目前，许多乌克兰人已经从想要与俄罗斯结盟转向想要与欧盟结盟。但俄罗斯仍然施加了很大的政治影响，国内存在可能长期制造麻烦的亲俄势力。尽管感觉去共产主义化法律的某些部分太模糊，但德劳诺娃认为在公共空间移除共产主义符号是一个重要的
step as Ukraine continues to develop as an independent nation. I think it is. I think it is because I think it should have been done earlier. It should be understood that it's never easy to do that. They all would always be a certain percent of the population who would strongly oppose that change. population would strongly oppose that change. It's tricky for Ukraine, for any country, really, to figure out how to leave behind symbols of oppression without completely denying and erasing the past. In Lithuania, which was also part of the USSR,
步骤，随着乌克兰继续发展成为一个独立的国家。我认为是这样。我认为是这样，因为我认为这应该早点完成。应该明白，这样做从来都不容易。总会有一定比例的人口强烈反对这种改变。这对乌克兰，对任何国家来说，弄清楚如何在不完全否认和抹去过去的情况下抛弃压迫的象征，都是一件棘手的事情。在同样曾是苏联一部分的立陶宛，
they threw a lot of their Lenin, Stalin, and Karl Marx statues into one park, Grudis Park, unofficially called, Stalin's World. And the park is open for visitors. So those people who feel very sentimental about the whole communist part and communist issues, they are welcome to come there,
他们把许多列宁、斯大林和卡尔·马克思的雕像扔进了一个公园——格鲁塔斯公园，非正式地被称为“斯大林的世界”。公园对游客开放。所以那些对整个共产主义部分和共产主义问题感到非常怀旧的人，欢迎来到那里，
visit and enjoy the view of the big land statues in the multiple variations around. Ukraine doesn't have any such park, but there have been some efforts to acknowledge the existence and loss of these monuments. For a week in 2016, a group got permission to put a temporary installation around the empty pedestal and Kiev
参观并欣赏各种各样的列宁大雕像。乌克兰没有任何这样的公园，但已经有一些努力来承认这些纪念碑的存在和损失。2016年的一周里，一个团体获得许可，在基辅的一个空基座周围放置了一个临时装置，
that used to hold the same linen we heard being toppled at the beginning of this story. The installation consisted simply of metal stairs that people could ascend to stand on a platform placed over the pedestal and then descend on the other side. In the process, they could see the world from Lenin's perspective. And of course, take a selfie.
那个基座曾经放置着我们在故事开头听到的被推倒的列宁雕像。该装置仅由金属楼梯组成，人们可以登上楼梯，站在放置在基座上方的平台上，然后从另一侧走下。在这个过程中，他们可以从列宁的角度看世界。当然，还可以自拍。
A Ukrainian curator who helped organize the installation says it's, quote, a way of asking what a monument is for, and everyone decides for themselves. That's because she says, decommunization starts first in the mind. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Julia Barton and Katie Mingle with Sharifusa, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. Kurt Colstead is Digital Director Terran Mazza is the Office Manager. Music This Week by Ok Akumi, Melodium, and our own, Sean Rial. Special thanks to David Marples, Alex Klymanov, Misha Friedman, and Katarina Draunova. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row.
一位帮助组织该装置的乌克兰策展人说，这“是一种询问纪念碑用途的方式，每个人自己决定”。这是因为她说，去共产主义化首先从思想开始。《99%隐形》本周由朱莉娅·巴顿和凯蒂·明格制作，参与人员包括谢里夫·乌萨、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，特兰·马扎是办公室经理。本周音乐由Ok Akumi、Melodium和我们自己的肖恩·里亚尔提供。特别感谢大卫·马普尔斯、亚历克斯·克莱马诺夫、米沙·弗里德曼和卡塔琳娜·德劳诺娃。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作。
In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. Remember radio topia is touring the west coast from May 8th through the 12th. If you're in Portland, Seattle, San Francisco, or LA, you have to be there. It's a requirement. Go to radiotopia.fm slash live for tickets. If you want to see us in San Francisco, this is pretty much your last chance for tickets. We're nearly sold out already. Portland is on the brink too, so act fast.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。记住，Radiotopia将于5月8日至12日在西海岸巡演。如果你在波特兰、西雅图、旧金山或洛杉矶，你必须去。这是一个要求。访问radiotopia.fm/live获取门票。如果你想在旧金山见到我们，这几乎是你最后的机会了。我们的票已经快卖光了。波特兰也快卖光了，所以行动要快。
We're in really big rooms in Seattle and LA, so you'd nerds better step up. I fought for you, called a couple of friends, and make a night of it. You know who's on the tour? Criminal. One of the first and still the best, true crime podcast. Yeah, you heard me.
我们在西雅图和洛杉矶的场地非常大，所以你们这些书呆子最好加把劲。我为你们争取了机会，叫上几个朋友，一起度过一个夜晚。你知道谁在巡演吗？《Criminal》。最早也是最好的真实犯罪播客之一。是的，你没听错。
Criminal tells stories of people who've broken the law and been caught, some people that've broken the law and been caught, some people that have broken the law and gotten away with it, victims, cops, and people caught somewhere in the middle. Every episode is completely different. You never quite know what you're going to get. Some are really hilarious, some are tragic, but I simply adore every single episode. It'll change the way you look at the world around you.
《Criminal》讲述了人们触犯法律并被抓获的故事，有些人触犯了法律却逃脱了惩罚，还有受害者、警察以及处于中间地带的人。每一集都完全不同。你永远不知道会听到什么。有些非常搞笑，有些则很悲惨，但我简直喜欢每一集。它会改变你看待周围世界的方式。
You need to see them live if you're on the West Coast, but if you can't be there for some dumb reason, get to know criminal at this is criminal.com or subscribe and I change the way you look at the world around you. You need to see him live if you're on the west coast, but if you can't be there for some dumb reason, get to know criminal at this is criminal.com or subscribe and iTunes, Google Play, or whatever you get podcasts. In addition to the tour, I also have a one-off live show in LA on April 14th with Helen Zoltzman of the Illusionist. It's a benefit show. All proceeds go to Arts4LA.
如果你在西海岸，你需要现场观看，但如果因为某些愚蠢的原因你无法到场，请通过thisiscriminal.com了解《Criminal》，或者在iTunes、Google Play或任何你获取播客的地方订阅。除了巡演，我还在4月14日与《The Illusionist》的海伦·佐尔茨曼在洛杉矶有一场单场现场演出。这是一场慈善演出。所有收益都捐给Arts4LA。
If you like art art and are a little nervous about art's funding as you should be, and like nerdy humor and obscure facts about seemingly boring things, this will be the night of your life. We'll have full details for the 99% Illusional Arts4LA benefit on our website. on our website. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if you want to read all about logo doppelgangers, that's been a very popular post this week. You have to go to 99pi.org. Radio to P.I. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢艺术，并且像你应该担心的那样对艺术资金感到紧张，并且喜欢书呆子式的幽默和关于看似无聊事物的冷知识，这将是你一生中最棒的夜晚。我们将在我们的网站上提供99% Illusional Arts4LA慈善演出的全部详情。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我@RomanMars，或者@节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。但如果你想阅读所有关于Logo替身的内容，那是本周非常受欢迎的一篇文章。你必须访问99pi.org。Radio to P.I. 来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。